one of the biggest stories in sports
over the last 24 hours has been about
Donald de LaHaye
he was a kicker I hate even saying was
for him but technically he was a kicker
at Central Florida he no longer is
because of NCAA rules and a result of
his YouTube channel and the profit that
he makes off of that and he joins us now
for a few minutes Donald why are you no
longer at n-c-double-a division one
football player or the ad revenue I was
generating from my youtube channel I
guess by later NCAA bylaws and I came in
try to offer me some conditions that I
wasn't too comfortable with I turned
them down and they you know it Dean be
ineligible before we get to the
conditions explain what a YouTube
channel is how you created it and what
you want it to be well I've always had a
passion for making videos ever since I
was young my dad was very involved in
the whole video thing so I've grown up
recording my life you know times with my
friends just hanging around footballs
big part of my life so I figured why not
film my adventures as a college football
player
were you surprised initially when they
channel took off and I was I mean I
wasn't expecting it to my channel grew
to around 60,000 subscribers in a
month's time so I was very shocked but
they'll happy to see on top why do you
think it grew to that level I feel like
I genuinely post good content I'm always
positive always inspirational people say
I'm funny I like to think I'm funny so I
think people just generally like
watching my content when did you
initially know that there could be an
issue with all of us well I monetized
May 9th not thinking much was going to
come from this and then the ground a
month later compliance officer called me
they told me there was issues with my
youtube channel and then after that risk
ala escalated to know Donald and talk
with Donald a LaHaye of course in the
Dan Patrick show haven't Cohen in hello
my bad check in for DP Donald is a
kicker Central Florida who's now
ineligible because of his YouTube
channel you said something that I think
needs some explanation when you decided
to monetize your channel explain what
that means for people may not understand
that and why you initially made that
decision
well everyone can post YouTube videos to
YouTube once you get to a certain
threshold around 10,000 views your
account gets reviewed and you're
eligible for monetization which means
you can replace ads on your videos and
they could generate revenue for you and
I got to that point past that point and
I monetize my videos and you know ever
since I started generating revenue it's
been a problem I would assume it's
public information so I don't think this
is too personal of a question how much
money were you making off of that just a
couple thousand bucks it's not nothing
huge nothing big enough to pay for my
college education but now something
holding me up and tell my family up what
was the offer that you see after the NC
double-a major well they told me I
couldn't make any videos involving my
this ism I couldn't talk about football
I couldn't hold the football I couldn't
kick a football past football couldn't
even be on the beach with my friends I
totally I asked if I could upload my
football videos unmonitored to my
channel they denied that that I had to
take all of them down and you know
donate all my money back to charity
oh wait I'm coming as well let me see if
I understand why you're saying that the
offer they made you in order to stay
eligible to stay on scholarship was
anything football-related it wasn't even
about the money it was about you
representing yourself as a UCF student
athlete with a football in your hand on
your feet in any way shape or form ya
had to be taken down it wasn't it wasn't
even that like they went as far as
saying I couldn't talk about
quarterbacks I miss kids making fun of
disposition groups and things like that
they told me I couldn't talk about
quarterback and it's clearly stated on
that waiver and right after that says
can't talk about quarterbacks etc so
that etc could be a lot more I don't
know about you know was there any part
of the offer Donald that they made that
you said okay I can live with that let's
try to build on that negotiate off of
that well at first they try to hype me
up and tell me while we're we're making
groundbreaking moves you know you're
you're about to change history this and
that they were hyping me up and then
when they came back to me with the news
from the n-c-double-a basically that
waiver wasn't waiting anything so I
didn't agree to it and they wanted you
to give your money back
yes they want me to donate every single
penny iron to a charity of my choice
okay so let's let's look at this big
picture
this is not about football it's probably
not even about the money you're making
it may not even be about your passion
your craft of filmmaking or video making
or if you want to look at it because as
you said it's not enough to pay for your
college your your seemingly correct me
if I'm wrong rightfully standing on
principle here against the n-c-double-a
correct yeah I mean it's constitutional
law I have a freedom of speech I could
do you know anything I really want not
really anything I want but as long as in
the rules I feel like I should be able
to have my own business and I should be
able to profit off of my own business
I'm building my brand I'm trying to
further my marketing degree that I'm
trying to attain I'm trying to apply
those to my current life and you know
I'm not allowed to
maybe me nose laughs so where do you
stand now where are you on scholarship
still where do you stand at Emory
University much scholarship has been
taken after return my iPad and move out
of my dorm room soon so yeah my wind
well they said the move out date was
August 4th which i think is a little
preposterous because I just got the news
literally a day two days ago so so you
were to pack up and move on July 31st
your scholarship is lifted you now need
to move out by August 4th and find
somewhere to live in essence Morgan
Smith well I got a phone call yesterday
saying that if I'm planning to stay in
my apartment right now I totally know if
I'm not on scholarship I can't pay for
it I go or the move out date is August
4th so you got to figure something out
Donald de LaHaye's our guests on the Dan
Patrick show have Ben Cohen Mike Babb
check-in for DPS the former UCF kicker
and youtube star who's had a scholarship
revoked now he has been deemed
ineligible by the NCAA
so is there is there a way to end this
in a happy way is there a way for you to
look at this and say we can fix this by
doing X Y & Z is there is there any kind
of light at the end of the tunnel for
you on this honestly I'm a positive guy
and I see tons of light at the end of
the tunnel you get a lot of
opportunities to run to me a lot of
people like what I do a lot of people
like my attitude my positivity
so they've been reaching out kay I'll
see this whole process that's kind of
made me fall out of love with Venus to
athlete so I'm happy with what's going
on right now I'm always going to be
happy which a matter what nobody could
take a smile off my face which part do
you dislike more the student part of the
athlete part you know I mean I don't
think we really get to be treated a
student so I guess the whole student
athlete term in general what do you mean
you don't get to be treated students do
you know a lot of college athletes and
whatnot go through these rules and
unfair tease of NCAA loss so I don't I
don't feel like a lot of things you know
make a lot of sense in there oh book we
don't get be treated normally a student
any regular student could create his own
business and drive off stone business
put them through school and I start
making a little bit of change and my
scholarship gets figure let's play
devil's advocate on this just for a
second I mean somebody probably has said
to you and I don't necessarily agree
with this but I'll throw this at you why
not just do what they're asking for now
bite the bullet for the next year and a
half two years get your education played
for a paid-for play football and then
restart your YouTube page after that
what's your argument against that is
honestly my youtube channel is thriving
and with that it's a hit or miss if you
don't post on YouTube for let's say a
week two weeks seems like a year it's
really hard again you're following back
and right now I want to strike while the
iron is hot
keep growing my channel and they were
trying to put me on hold and I wasn't
really down for that you know now this
may be a dumb question can you get a
scholarship to a university whether it's
Central Florida or somewhere else based
on your movie slash filmmaking your
YouTube channel I mean is that is still
a marketing a video skill that would
garner a scholarship anywhere I think so
there's a lot of even film schools I
don't know how they offer scholarships
and things like that but I'm sure if
engineers could get scholarships what
they're doing a filmmaker and a marketer
like myself could also get a scholarship
the most famous person that has reached
out to you through this process to try
to help you through it is
market king raiders corner my guy he's
like a big brother to me got to hang out
with him for a couple days at his house
in Arizona I changing experience man I'm
extremely thankful for him one of the
biggest influencers and motivators in my
life and what did he tell you to do
through all of this you just told me to
always remain myself and you know it
might be trying to shut you down and
this and that but don't let anyone you
know stop you from being you always be
yourself always be happy
don't let haters you know put a frown on
your face just smile through everything
and be positive what's your dream jump
my dream job I don't really have a dream
job I love videos you know hang out with
athletes and they'll have fun things
like that I'm really living my dream job
right now creating YouTube content I get
to ask when I get to go around the boat
people had you know still get paid at
the end of the day so pretty much had a
Microsoft right now is there any chance
that this changes is there any chance
you go back to them and say you know
let's I'll take the deal so after all
this nah I don't think so and the anger
that you have right now we'll finish
with this you're more annoyed more angry
with the n-c-double-a or UCF did we lose
him we may have lost them it was awesome
man well listen it's fascinating you
know because initially when I heard this
obviously the entities ridiculous when I
heard this I mean it's absurd it's
absurd obviously that they're doing this
to him that he can't earn money off of a
YouTube page but I initially thought the
offer that UCF /a incidentally made him
was to still do this does not take the
money I didn't realize he could he could
not only take the money he'd have to
give the money back and then not do
anything football-related
I mean that that part was unbelievable
to me I mean that's absurd I mean that's
the n-c-double-a for you the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience
you